- Sex sent them to the ER.
For this, I needed a
consultation from my good friend,
Dr. Rena Malik.
Welcome to the channel.
- Thanks so much for having me.
- Are you excited to watch the show?
- I'm so excited.
- And I've heard you
watched a couple episodes.
- I watched one, yeah.
- Be-woop.
- It looks like your penis
has sustained major trauma.
What is all of this?
- It was ...
- It's like a chastity belt?
- [Narrator] Wearing a
medieval torture device
is probably not most
people's idea of a good time,
but this man had been unfaithful before,
so this couple thought it was necessary.
- I've not seen a
patient who's been forced
to wear one because
they've been unfaithful.
- Yeah, that's a punishment as opposed.
I mean, maybe they want the
punishment, so like S&M,
you gotta be open to that adult play.
- [Narrator] After lovemaking,
this couple went through
their bizarre ritual,
and she'd take the key
and lock him up until they'd meet again.
- The bit that hurts, the
power to make it work,
my favorite part.
- Wow.
- I'm the only one with
the key to your ...
- What would happen if you were
to get an erection trapped
inside of a plastic case?
It would hurt.
- It would hurt,
and you could possibly
damage your penis, right?
If the erection was bent a different way,
you could create micro tears in the penis,
which over time could cause
problems with erectile function.
- [Mitch's Girlfriend]
Oh my gosh, my necklace.
The key, I've lost it.
- You've what?
(both shouting)
- Mitch?
- You're gonna break me free.
- Brace yourself.
- Oh no.
(hammer smashes)
(girl shouts)
- Yeah, we do see things get
stuck on penises all the time.
People will use different
things as cock rings
and then they'll fall asleep,
they'll be intoxicated,
or they will have an erection
and then it gets swollen
and then it gets stuck.
You have to use all
sorts of different things
like Gigli saws to cut
'em off, but not a hammer.
- Fortunately, it looks like
just abrasions and contusions.
- There's no role here for an ultrasound
to check for hematomas?
I feel like--
- Well, so you can get an MRI
to make sure there's no fracture,
but ultimately if there's just hematomas
or you know, essentially
blood clots or, you know,
blood forming underneath the foreskin,
there's really nothing you need to do
but wait for some time.
- Please, just get these things out of me.
- Okay, things.
- Get what out of you?
- [Both] The rocks, okay, the rocks.
- Hey, let's use these.
- Pop rocks?
- Candy rocks.
- Are those that pop?
I was gonna say that,
but then I was like, "That's ridiculous."
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
- A raging yeast infection.
- Here, in here, they're burning.
Oh, it hurts.
- There's lot of swelling and irritation.
- Use toys or devices, aids that are used,
that are meant for sexual purposes.
They have, you know, flavored
lube, flavored condoms.
Make sure to try them
on your skin before you
try them down there.
- Smart.
- To make sure you're not having
an allergic reaction or something,
but some of these things
can put you at a higher risk
for yeast infections
like you talked about.
- I better put it somewhere else.
I wonder what it'd feel like down there.
- I tell her, you know,
this isn't a good idea.
We probably shouldn't be doing this.
- Sugar is not meant to be in that area.
- Yeah, generally speaking, yeah.
You wanna keep sticky icky things away
from the genitals.
- [Dr. Mike] Good point.
- [Narrator] After the popsicle melted,
this couple went to heat
things up in the bedroom.
- [Bald Man] She was
squirming around quite
a bit more than normal,
so I kind of figured
something was wrong, there was
some tenderness or something.
- Oh no.
- So I was hoping it
was just an infection.
- An infection that
quickly is unreasonable.
- I really don't want to tell the story,
so I was really vague with the doctor.
And we were using, you
know, sort of a sex toy.
- This is so common, I'll just tell you,
that people never wanna say
exactly what they were doing.
Very often, they were like
minding their own business
or something else or you
know, they make up a story
'cause they're super embarrassed.
- What's the wildest
story you've ever heard?
Like, not wildest.
Like, the worst example where
it's obviously unbelievable.
- Well, so there was a guy
who was cheating on his wife
and he came in for a penile fracture,
which is where you, if you
have vigorous intercourse
and you break the penis essentially,
that's a surgical emergency.
So he came in and he told his wife he
was masturbating in the car
and that's how it happened.
(Dr. Mike laughs)
- Popsicle, okay?
It was a popsicle.
That's what we used as a sex toy.
And after a while, I just got numb to it.
- You definitely gave
yourself cold panniculitis.
- That's a quick diagnosis.
- Yeah.
- Cold panniculitis.
Cold panniculitis in my head
is like kind of like frostbite.
Is that reasonable?
- Yeah, I think so.
I think that's reasonable.
I mean, it's basically exposure to cold
that leads to an eruption
of the skin causing,
you know, kind of a rash-like syndrome.
- [Nurse] Should clear up in a few days.
We'll get you some ointment
to take care of the inflammation.
- I'm assuming they're gonna throw
some corticosteroid on that?
- Probably; you know what
we learned in med school?
When it's dry, make it wet.
When it's wet, make it dry.
- A popsicle is not a sex toy.
- Just like how we say, if
your icing an injured area,
you don't apply the ice
directly to the skin
'cause you could damage the skin.
That's, essentially burning your skin
with ice.
- Absolutely.
- Which is counterintuitive, right?
Burning with ice.
- Yeah.
- My husband has a problem
with his private parts.
- It's my penis.
It's all red and swollen.
- Why, when we talk about our bodies,
we get so uncomfortable?
What, that happens often.
- Oh, anything, it starts
when we're young, right?
If your parents don't
teach you the right words
for vagina and penis, you
know, you're like my hoohah,
my this, my, you know, and it becomes
like an embarrassing thing,
and it's part of culture.
- That penis looked like a
kielbasa with speed bumps.
These bumps on your penis,
are they some kind of beads?
He said, "Those are glass
beads that have been implanted
"in the skin of my penis."
- We like his penis the way it is.
That's all you need to know.
- People have injected many
things into their penis, right?
There's a, there's a big
population in prisons
that does a lot of injecting of fillers.
- Really?
- And actually, these beads,
it's penis pearling,
I believe it's called.
They, it started in Asia
with this crime syndicate.
I think it's called, I can't remember.
For every year they were in prison,
they would insert another pearl.
- They weren't doing it as a punishment.
It was like a positive thing?
- [Dr. Rena] Correct, to
show like how manly they are.
- Just use a ribbed condom.
- Exactly.
That's the same thing.
- It's the same thing, right?
- The infection could spread
and you could lose a lot
more than just the bead.
It could be fatal.
- Get it out, please.
- So the procedure that we
use it we numb the area,
then I make a small incision,
in this case over the bead,
and then pop the bead out.
Gotcha, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
Okay, we're done.
You did great.
- And then you leave the
rest of the beads in there?
- Well, if they got infected,
in theory, you could leave 'em in there.
- I saw a man's genitals swollen
and slightly bluish, discolored.
At the base of them was
this large steel ring.
- A ring on the testicles?
- Baby, you look terrible.
This is all my fault.
- [Dan] Oh, hello.
- Hi.
- [Narrator] How can a man's
girlfriend bringing home
a new accessory from a sex
toy party be a bad thing?
- I don't think that's
gonna fit around me.
- [Girlfriend] It doesn't
go around just that.
It goes around everything.
- Some people get pleasure from
perineal stimulation, right?
So when you're tugging on it,
the erectile bodies of the
penis go down into the perineum.
Whenever you're using rings,
you wanna use ones that are silicone,
that can stretch really easily
or have some sort of release valve.
Otherwise, you'll end up
in a situation like this.
- I can't get it off.
- Oh my God, Danny.
- I need to go to the ER.
- Dan, it looks like the
only way we're gonna be able
to get this ring off is by cutting it off.
- What kind of saw, you said earlier--
- A Gigli saw.
- [Dr. Mike] What's a Gigli?
I never thought I'd ask that.
What's a Gigli saw?
- You know, I don't
really know what it is.
We just know that's
what we have to call for
and sometimes we have to
call the fire department
if the ER doesn't have one.
- But then they bring that giant thing?
- Yeah.
- This ring was bigger
and thicker than most of the
rings that I've seen before,
but I figure, "Well, let me see
if we can cut through that."
(saw buzzes)
- Yeah, I've used one of those before too.
- I feel like you could
put like a piece of metal
to protect the--
- Yes, so you can get
like a small malleable blade from the OR
and put it underneath so
that it hits that instead.
- We're gonna need a bigger tool.
- Oh, here you go.
- I told you.
- They got the fire department.
- Why are they holding
him like he's gonna jump?
- Hold him still, okay?
(Danny shouts)
I was, frankly, a little worried.
You know, could I pull this off?
(Danny shouts)
All right, here we go.
Ready?
And the ring is off.
- That was a scary way of doing it.
- [Narrator] This man had a close call,
so here's some advice for you ladies too.
Just because you like it
doesn't mean you should put a ring on it.
(distorted laughing)
- She seemed to be having
this fantastic orgasm.
It was as though we were still having sex,
even though we had
stopped for some minutes.
(Liz pants)
Liz, it's almost 8:30.
The meter maids are coming soon.
You've gotta move your car.
- Well, it won't stop.
- What?
Are you still having an orgasm?
- Yes.
- So I don't know
about having long orgasms.
Certainly usually don't last this long,
but you can have persistent
genital arousal disorder,
which is a rare condition
that happens in mostly women,
where they have persistent
feelings of arousal
and the same changes
that happen in your body
when you're aroused and having orgasms,
like blood flow to the area
and sometimes sensitivity
can continue to occur.
It can very distressing
and actually uncomfortable.
It's not like a pleasurable scenario.
(Liz moans)
- Coming in the door in a full orgasm.
- Let's give her some diazepam, all right?
And run those tests.
- So they went to a dispensary
to try and get the Valium,
and while they were still
writing up the paperwork, I stopped.
- That's gotta be traumatizing
if the next time you
have sex, you're like, "Whoa,
what if that happens again?"
- Yeah, and usually,
so with these patients
who have it persistently and
not in this short period,
it can be like extremely
distressing and up to 54%
of people like say they'll
have suicidal ideation.
I mean, it's really serious.
- It got to the point
where I could just be
like doing whatever, watching
TV, walking down the street,
and I could have an
orgasm out of the blue.
I would have as many as 12 spontaneous,
prolonged orgasms in one day.
At the end of the day, after
a lot of research was done,
they finally determined that I'm bipolar
and they had to switch
me from antidepressants
to bipolar meds.
- So I guess this was
like the mania component
of the bipolar?
- I think it was probably PGAD,
or persistent genital
arousal syndrome or disorder.
Again, they can be treated
with antipsychotics.
So maybe she had other
emotional symptoms as well,
but I think that was--
- Yeah, I don't think you
can make a diagnosis of bipolar disorder
off of just that one symptom.
- [Dr. Rena] Right.
- So there had to be other things
that they're not sharing.
- [Dr. Malik] Right.
- [Liz] I have a very happy sex life
and that's a really great feeling.
- Well, that's great, 'cause I worry
that by taking medications,
could you hurt your sex life?
Could there be sexual dysfunction
as a result of the medicine?
- Yeah, so SSRIs have side
effects of low libido.
Very commonly, if you
do develop low libido
on these medications, they
can either change medications
or add medications to help with libido,
so if you're suffering from that,
talk to your psychiatrist or doctor,
whoever's prescribing it.
- I'm sorry, I didn't
mean to hurt you, baby.
- He gave her a look at
one point, which said
to me apparently there was
something more going on.
The vacuum hose was attached to his penis
and his left testicle was trapped inside.
- We use vacuum erection devices
for men with erectile dysfunction,
but they're a controlled suction, right?
So in this case, you know,
it's uncontrolled suction.
- When I examined his genital region,
I see swelling and bruising,
and the scrotal sac could be compromised.
And of course, the penis could
be suffering injury as well.
I begin cutting the
vacuum hose with the saw.
(saw buzzes)
- Did he need to bring this?
Like, why is there sparks?
It's not metal.
- Everyone heaves a great sigh of relief,
but our celebration is short-lived.
It's clear that his genitals
are swollen, they're bruised.
They really look to be in poor shape.
- If you have something that's on there
for a significant period of time,
yeah, it's gonna constrict and constrict,
and then it's gonna cause
swelling beyond the constriction,
and then it will just start
getting bigger and bigger.
And over time, yes, you
can cause blood flow
to decrease to the penis,
so you wanna get it taken care
of as quickly as possible.
- Because of the size of the hematocele,
which is a collection of blood,
it was very likely that the circulation
to the testicle was compromised.
- Is that bad?
- Yes, we'll have to
operate immediately or else.
(dramatic music)
- Doors open, in come the
paramedics with this lady.
Can you open your eyes?
Let's get her to this bed.
Non-verbal, pale, she's in shock.
She needs immediate intervention.
Can you tell me exactly what happened?
- You know, my Papu died
and it's been really
stressful on everyone.
- This had occurred after
the death of a family member.
- [Narrator] At the wake,
they snuck off for some alone time.
- Seriously, what are you doing?
- I'm ovulating.
- [Narrator] When this husband
wasn't able to perform,
they broke into grandpa's
prescription stash.
- Who has funerals in their own homes?
- I don't know.
- [Dr. Mike] At the person
who's deceased home, especially?
- I know she's ovulating,
but she's gonna be ovulating
for a couple--
- [Dr. Mike] Tonight.
- Yeah, it doesn't have to
happen during the funeral.
- And also, perfectly acceptable to not
be in a sexual mood at a funeral.
- Absolutely, I think that's a big thing
in men's sexual health, right?
It's okay that you are not
always ready to perform,
and I think that adds so much
anxiety and so much stress
for men when women are
like, "Why can't you?"
- What I've seen pattern-wise emerge
is my female patients try to
always look physically perfect
to their friends and family members.
The male patient's always
trying to be mentally perfect,
so they might not smell great and that,
but they only have to be tough
and strong and aggressive.
- Hey, what's this?
Nitropaste.
- All right, open it up.
- How do they know physiology so well
that they're like, "We know
how nitro paste works."
- I know, they're like let's
put this on your penis.
Like, what?
- Grandpa's heart medication.
- Gets the blood flowing, right?
Let's try it out.
Wow.
- Whoa.
- That worked better than I expected.
- Would that work?
Like, I don't even know if
that's like a treatment.
- I think that increases nitric oxide,
what increased blood flow to the penis
and then caused an erection,
so potentially, yes.
Do not recommend.
- Yeah, okay, sure.
- Sam?
Oh my God, Sam, what's the matter?
- So she's basically
experiencing systemic effects
of the nitro, where she's vasodilating
so much so that it's
dropping her blood pressure.
- But I'm surprised he's
not, because nitropaste
is meant to be absorbed topically,
so why is he not getting
any symptoms that she is?
- And that's the last thing I remember.
- Dude, you had sex in Papu's house
and used his medicine at his wake?
That's crazy.
- How is this show on the air?
(both laughing)
Huge thank you to Dr.
Malik for coming over.
Check out her channel.
And if you wanna see some
more TLC shows, click here.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)